welcome to this video playing LLM jump
whatever that means this is this some
some Latin number they are not the
correct one at least okay so we have the
Rubenstein French and he's some playing
um somewhat old-fashioned defense here
which doesn't mean that it's bad I'm
just saying it is old-fashioned really
giving me tempo
c5 is not bad here anyway okay I'll take
this takes a bit of time but two bishops
are two bishops
Plus this may be the additional tempo
take Sam Bishop f4
yeah he would like to go to his seven
but the specialty six
they are probably back to the aid yeah
but this should be five coming
threatening to trap the Queen this
really cannot be better okay so before
him I need to support Wow Wow
my majority anyway group Jake's I guess
can I just take and play b5 i beliee
candy can actually capture this isn't
completely clear
okay I need to take you anyway but now
b5
yeah but why isn't this clear actually
let's let's do that
b5 a baby Bishop b5 Queen B Sam it's not
winning
some are disappointing that it looks
like it should win
maybe this will be fine threatening b5
this could be could be could be good
maybe we should be seven you know I play
b5
this was the idea all along now Bishop
c4 on c6 yeah come on let's let's grab
material
the only issue smacking it's in the
middle and to be a bit cautious that I'm
not winning material but somehow getting
caught with the bad king so yeah
attacking the Queen I think it's better
than then grabbing even more material
okay so maybe maybe this
I only need basically a bishop move and
then then castles okay with the temple I
don't mind that check and no castles
there should be out of the woods
hmm yeah maybe yeah
this was bitter maybe one wasn't so
precise
Bishop c4 okay and I just need to
activate stuff him this the pieces in
the corner are not exactly active
this bishop needs to go to e5 this is
the key to to improve him check
kwinto h88 attacking dusim champion and
I don't mind getting the Queen's off
it's it's just easier
f/4g for its meat
black resigns yeah just an opening
opening disaster yeah I'm not sure this
this this already seems nice but yeah I
think he just needs to go back to the
eighth get out of harm's way this just
runs into further Tempe yeah yeah this
is this is probably winning with good
technical play it's not I'm not quite
sure that I managed to do that playing
good technically there should be seven
here was also much much tougher and this
is this is winning just the just pawns
when a piece what you need so it needs
to go here and this isn't completely
over probably I need to just just
develop and complete complete my my
development here it's it's it's
certainly nice for white but not the win
after it should be seven no ever be five
it's it's just gone those pawns are too
strong alright thanks for watching